♪ ♪ ♪blblblblblblblblblblblblbl.
Un gros cinq sous qui surplombe
la ville, non pas en hommage
à la monnaie, mais au nickel
- Et c'est ça, qu'on chasse,
dans nos mines.
- Longtemps surnommée la ville
sous-sol regorgent de minerais.
Une richesse qui s'explique par
l'impact d'une météorite il y
plus d'un milliard d'années.
JENNUDUDUDUDUDRY, scientifique
senior, Science Nord
- No
autour de l'impact de Sudbury.
- Ce n'est qu'nnnnn
du 19e siècle que les premiers
gisements sont découverts.......
- On a eu un gros boom. C'est
vraiment là qu'on a vu beaucoup
de gens déménager dans la
♪ ♪ ♪
- Pendant des décennies, Sudbury
profite de son b
Mais au tournant des années 80,
la
du prix des métaux.
Même chose en 2008 lorsque
de plusieurs mines.
de nouveau pour Sudbury,
avec une hausse
du prix du nickel. La tonne
est passée d'environ 18 500 $sss
de 34 000 $ aujourd'hui.
Le mois dernier, un sommet
de 100 000
lors d'un épisode de frénésie
boursière
la production d'un claquement
de doigt, au c
- C'est la guerre en Ukraine
qui escecececececececececececec.
La Russie, durement sanctionnée
par l'Occident, produit environ
10 % du nickel mondial.
émérite, Université Laurentienne
- Toute tensioeeeeeee
vient causer des hausses de
prix pratiquement automatiques.
qui explique cette tendance l ln
écologique aussi a un rôle
à jouer, puisque ààààààààààààààn
de batteries de véhicules
électriques.
- Aujourd'hui, on fait face à ce
de 50 % de la demande dansrerers
qui viennent et éventuellement
probablement un doubleme
ou plus de la demande mondiale.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Une bonne nouvelle pourd'd'd's
dépendent encore de l'industrie
minière. Les deux
multinationales présentes
dans lououououououououououououot
l'agrandissement de mines
existantes ou la réouverture
de sites fermés. Ce syndicaliste
700 mineurs du Grand Sudbury.
Pour lui,
les beaux jours sont à venir.pr,
on verra beaucoup plus d'emplois
dans les mines", prévoit L L L s
du travail que dans les mines.
À Sudbury, isisisisisisisisisist
des services indirectement liés
à l'industrie minière.nenenenent
de l'équipement spécialisé pour
automatiser certaines étapes
du processus de forage.
Avec une centaine
de Walter Siggelkow estununununs
de Sudbury. Et avec la hausse
des prix d
Même écho pour cette autre
entreprise, qui fournit
de l'équipement de haute
dans le monde, y compris
à Sudburyêêêêêêêêêêêêêêêêêêêêêê,
avertit Michael, mais ça ne peut
pas être de l'optimisme
aveugle."
Car pour tirer profit
de ltetetetetetetetetetete
pour le nickel, Sudbury
difficile d'en augmenter
rapidement la production,
ouvrir une nouvelle mine coûte
de dollars et prend des années.
À cela s'ajoute le fait
que l'industrie minière
soudaine des prix peut toujours
su
C'est pourquoi la
Sudbury surveille avec attention
l'évolution des prix du nickel.
et continue à miser sur ladeded.
qu'il y a de bonnes raisonstiti.
"L'avenir de Sudbury est
très prometteur si on regarde
électriques", dit-elle.
Un enthousiasme qu'on ressent
partout dans la ville,
de nombreux mineurs parmi
se
Pour l'instant, Mathieu
du nickel ne s'est pas encore
concrétisé
à manger.
MATHIEU ST-PIERRE, directeur
- Il n'y a pas des mineurs qui
nenenenenenenenenenenenenes
de dollars d'argent puis ils
lancent là quand ils rentr
- Mais le moral de ses clientstt
au rendez-vous.
- Il yueueueueueueueueueueueueui
va continuer. Tout le monde
a plus de confiance à dépenser
un peu plus sur des restaurants.
♪ ♪ ♪
- L'attente pour que Sudbury
vovevevevevevevevevevevevevevevl
pourrait être longue.
Mais dans une ville qui
a longtemps vécu au rythmererers
les bonnes nouvelles.
Et encore moins, les promesses
d'un nouvel El Dor